[MUSIC] I
could go home forever, like the sound of it.  It looks
like you can use the magic you have. Let's
put it on here and open it.
Specifically, how much is
100 Asura gold coins?
Is it higher than that? It doesn't look like it's
going to be a big deal Even if you enter 10,
you won't get a big catch, right? Action This is attractive, isn't it?
Even in the city now, I wonder what is important to him.If he understands it, he will
rise to the top very slowly.
Up until now, I've been living without worrying about money at all.I've lived a
NEET life for nearly 20 years.My reflection on
being covered in eroge, my sister, and women.With
that narrow experience, you can understand the
meaning of betraying a young lady here,
here, Miss o.  I'm
sorry, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
No,
Paul was in
Black Shinryu has a sword-throwing technique
[music] [
applause]
[music]
car